thank you it's a pleasure to be here
thanks organizer for the invitation so
what I will try to go through some of
the examples from our work on cancer
genomics proteomics and some of the
experiences and hopefully steer some of
the kind of questions for the discussion
in the afternoon so on the kind of
vertical side we can definitely go
through computational biology or
integrative computational biology cancer
informatics through integrating diverse
distributed and heterogeneous data set
so we can build different pipelines for
analysis of individual kinds of data and
then through different kind of networks
physical protein interactions
transcriptional Network micro need to
gene Network drug target networks and so
on link them in order to identify
potentially interesting models that we
can computationally build validate and
planned future experiments for
validation or for understanding the
biology of it on the horizontal side we
can take a more kind of personalized
medicine or individualized precision
medicine approach where we take
different kind of clinical factors
different molecular measurements and
also lifestyle or other markers and
combine them through different kind of
machine learning and knowledge discovery
platforms to identify different
subgroups not only of the markers but
then also of the phenotypes or patients
so we can for example identify or
distinguish patients with a high risk of
disease love the risk of disease
response potential response to a
treatment and so on so kind of different
kind of stratification through those
different integration the challenge is
obviously we don't know which
combination of these will be important
we don't know where is the noise coming
from there is different kind of missing
values there is different kind of noise
and so on that I will explore later on
or how kind of highlight yesterday there
were already several talks that were
discussing various challenges that we
have in this kind of endeavor which goes
from heterogeneity both in terms of time
and space of the samples intra and Inter
tumor heterogeneity s there are
different biases in terms of the data
collection different errors that come
into play but I will also try to focus
on some of the aspects of where we have
ignorance where we try to build models
based on an incorrect data and how can
we find that something is not correct
and potentially improve on
obviously as we are entering this data
driven medicine and biology a lot of the
biological information turns into the
numbers once we have numbers there's all
sorts of statistical errors mistakes and
so on that we can do or hide certain
mistakes and errors and obviously his
story told us that there is various ways
how we can have a scientific argument we
can burn witches or as we head for
example with Edison and Nikola Tesla
argument about the AC current
electrocuting large animals to display
how AC current is dangerous to humankind
and obviously we know where the history
is so sometimes people go into
extraordinary lengths you know to prove
somebody else wrong and only history
will show otherwise so some of these
open challenges is how can we find
different biomarkers and signatures and
how can we be sure that it's relatively
complete set of those markers how can we
then build models so we can understand
the disease mechanism and progression
but also for example drag mechanism of
action in which meta-analysis obviously
depends on what are we analyzing and
what kind of data we are using for these
kind of analysis and I will highlight
some of those things and through that
definitely networks and so-called
pathways are essential in order to help
us to understand really what's the
relationship between the biology and the
disease but we had to deal with
different false positives and false
negatives what is the context when they
are relevant what is the coverage and
importantly also was the ground truth
that we are comparing any of these
mentioned learning or data mining
algorithms to so how can we successfully
analyze false positives and negatives so
there's a kind of starting example we
are looking at is some of the data from
TCGA squamous cell lung carcinoma and
it's basically integrating through the
network everything that at the time we
knew about lung cancer squamous cell
carcinoma so it's integrating micro RNA
gene expression sequencing data mutation
and also integrating it through the
physical protein interactions also
micronet to gene targeting networks and
also integrating on top of it what we
knew about what are the prognostic genes
in the lung cancer what are the
significantly up
regulated genes within lung cancer and
so on so these kind of figures or
integration not only enables you to
interpret the results from these large
collections of data sits across
different types of high-throughput
platforms but also generate models of
what potentially really is important
through for example identifying shortest
paths or strongly connected components
within these networks in order to do
that as yesterday for example orange
Amir was showing we can integrate a
large volume of this data from geo or
rather publicly available resources or
from literature however garbage in
garbage out so as pointed yesterday we
had to do curation in order to trust the
information that we have so for that
purpose we started data integration
portal focusing on some of the cancers
and later on on some other diseases and
in principle you can view it as can we
try to collect everything and anything
on those diseases across different
conditions response to treatment
mutation expression profiles and so on
so we can view it that rose in the large
database will be individual genes and
columns in the table will be different
types of analyses that will identify
specific genes to be significantly the
regulated under certain condition
however what is critically important is
that we collect also clinical
information that goes with it sometimes
it might be easier than in other times
surprisingly there are many gene
expression profiles will be hard-pressed
to find quality information about the
survival or in lung cancer smoking
history or rice or EGFR mutation status
and if you don't help such information
you might have the gene expression or
rather profiles but it's going to be
useless for clinical application the
other thing though I want to highlight
is permission learning we want to train
the model on one dataset and ideally
independently validate on different
datasets independent data set however is
highlighted in lung cancer we have to be
careful because we might have
independent data sets independent pubmed
IDs yet the same patient samples are
sometimes cross used across the studies
as highlighted we have over 6,000
patient sample profiles but only about
four and a half thousand are unique so
this problem is quite substantial and we
have to be careful because it can lead
to significant errors that i will as
will show later on for overestimation of
performance as I was mentioning earlier
for example as surprising as it is very
relatively small fraction of lung cancer
that does it have information about the
smoking status or detailed information
about smoking status and from other
studies we already know that it's very
critical to know if it's a former smoker
but what former smoker what it means
that they quit three weeks ago or three
years ago or 30 years ago it's shown
here in this study there are very
significant changes on a micro RNA
deregulation level depending on the
status of the smoking and that leads to
different regulation of genes across or
specific genes across those different
subgroups and it has a severe
implications and survival of these
patients so all of this information is
critical to understand as I was
mentioning earlier it's critical to
build model on one dataset and
independent validation as shown in
ovarian cancer example few years back
perfect separation of patients in one
data sets training data set but
completely missing the separation on
independent validation data set so we
try to use information of these
deregulated genes with new approach of
combining information from the networks
in order to identify better prognostic
groups of genes so it took set of genes
that were highly deregulated in ovarian
cancer across a large number of samples
but then so it's kind of shrinking down
the set of interesting jeans but then we
expanded a set of interesting genes
based on what is potentially related to
their biology so we started to look into
their interacting partners and then we
used a relatively straightforward lasso
penalized Kobe regression model in order
to identify smaller set of 14 genes that
were prognostic for ovarian cancer going
into independent validation it was quite
promising so we were following up
further with it and using data from
jinsuk DB from broad that has collection
of prognostic signatures across multiple
diseases including ovarian cancer there
were 28 prognostic signatures that were
published before and we wanted to
evaluate them de novo based on a hazard
ratio on too large over
today that's a total investment and
these numbers are basically related to
PubMed IDs so you can see our signature
validated quite favorably compared to
the other signatures on both of these
datasets but there was one signature
that was basically twice as good as any
other signature on a Dressman data set
but one of the poorest on a total data
set so as soon as you see this kind of
strong difference in terms of how
invalid that across two independent data
says it kind of begged the question why
and what was interesting is that 30
patient samples that were used for
training this model were actually
overlapping with the investment data set
again proving the point that this is
over true i mean it's it's training and
testing on a partially overlapping data
set in our case we then switch gears
signature was based on mrna expression
levels and we were looking for good
antibodies for the signature we found 8
of those and we validated the signature
now on a protein level on completely
independent cohort with a different
method and it validated both in terms of
the prevalence and also intensity of
expression of these individual proteins
so now combining deregulated genes with
their with their interacting partners
proved very interesting because only two
of the genes in the signature were
actually strongly differential jeans
everything else came from the network
and meaning not strongly overlapping
genes differentially expressed genes the
other aspect that I wanted to highlight
is there are multiple different
signatures looking at the protein
interaction network and as you can see
they don't really overlap highly because
each of these studies identified one
signature and because there are a large
number of possible signatures the
individual genes from those signatures
may have clinical validity but they
don't overlap across this is very much
kind of recapitulating but few years
back we identified in lung cancer we're
individual prognostic signatures
actually overlap very in a very small
way and many other people also show the
one of the reason is that we would need
to identify thousands of signatures
before we would start to see some kind
of convergence of these individual genes
that form the signature
and in one of the papers we actually
pushed it further and we did near
exhaustive identification of sixteen
signatures and identified almost 2,000
prognostically interesting signatures
that were comprised of six genes each
now what was really intriguing from
analyzing that set of genes that we
identified so-called best supporting
actors because large fraction of genes
that were not significantly
differentially expressed but they were
significantly contributing to those
signatures being clinically relevant or
valid and those signatures validated on
multiple independent data sets and
combined data set so another kind of
aspect to kind of highlight is as I
alluded to further is later on we had
9515 gene prognostic and predictive
signature and it's again same as I
showed already twice it doesn't overlap
with previews validated clinical
signatures in lung cancer but through
the protein interaction network we can
link it so we can find relevance or
linkages through these signaling
cascades represented as protein
interaction network but as you may be
able to see some of the proteins are
strongly linked and have many different
connections and others are orphans or
they don't have interactions not because
they don't interact but because we don't
have those interactions validity of that
signature was quite substantial because
we were able to show on independent
validation again that we can completely
change the treatment of non-small cell
lung cancer because adding adjuvant
chemotherapy significantly improved or
reverse high-risk patients into more
survivals and success story was that
hello mix from Pittsburgh now markets
this as a generic slunk prognostic gene
set once we have these signatures I
mentioned that we can also try to
understand how drug works or potentially
identify different combination therapies
so we took combination of lung cancer
signatures and use the cmap data to
identify ranked individual genes that
will be potentially useful for treating
lung cancer based on
we know about the deregulation of these
individual genes in these signatures
through that process we had identified
about 250 drugs and subset of those we
then were able to validate
retrospectively on NCI 60 data said
we're on all of the 9 line cancer cell
lines they actually have stronger
inhibition than the other drugs that
were available now it validated our
approach because we de novo were
predicting which drugs might be
potentially useful for lung cancer but
in terms of the lung cancer field
nothing shattering because you can go to
NCI 60 and you would get the same
information so we be it was we took this
23 drugs that now validated we took
their structure and identify 11 other
drugs that were not tested on NCI 60 but
we predicted them as potentially useful
that first structurally similar and what
is interesting is that even on PubMed
there is very little discussion about
using of those drugs for neoplasms or
treating cancer and long story short of
for lung cancer cell lines we were able
to show that the top-ranking drag from
that set was able to inhibit growth and
more importantly it's not only the
phenotype that we were looking for but
we were also able to identify in olives
for different cell lines that the genes
that we predicted should be reversed as
after the applique transcriptionally
reversed after the application of the
drugs they did significantly change so
it's not only identifying the phenotype
but also having a mechanism how does
that work so going back to the
signatures I highlighted that there are
multiple signatures that we can identify
but we don't have computational power to
find them all so we started a project
with IBM world community grid mapping
cancer markers to try to kind of push
for identifying stronger these
signatures and as I have highlighted
before two aspects to be remembered one
is if we take univariate analysis and
compared to the signature signature
beats any single gene most of the time
all of the time that's one part of the
message but the other part of the
message is that the second-worst gene on
an individual basis is actually the
third-best gene when we have a signature
so that's an important aspect for this
Best Supporting Actor
that something that is ridiculously
unusable and we would most of most
likely filter it out before we will be
trying to search for the best signature
we would filter it out before we will
have a chance of identifying what is
really intriguing is that this
recapitulate two different sizes of
signatures so this is univariate versus
signature but when we compare signature
of different size 10 and 40 genes or
probes same order of probes on both
graphs and the height of individual bars
shows how important is that significant
are contributing to the signature of a
specific size and we can see that the
gene that is media karina 10 gene
signature is now best marker in a 40
gene signature so finding the good
signature obviously is a factor of how
big signature are we looking for and
there are many different aspects that we
have to consider one is large signatures
have a broader applicability across more
heterogeneous populations of patients
but obviously smaller signature is more
clinically plausible in terms of the
cost noise and so on so one has to be
careful how we optimize these two parts
and the jury is still out there what
will be necessary without going into the
project is still going but without going
into too much detail I want to highlight
again the aspect that the most
interesting jeans now that includes
differential jeans and a best supporting
actors for large-scale analyses on a
broad community grid also shows that
some of them we have a large number of
information about who they are
interacting with and for many of them we
have absolutely no information who they
are interacting with so interact the
more phones we cannot build models we
cannot understand how they link to
signaling cascades and that brings us to
another example of why type of data that
we use for this protein interactions and
pathways is essential because it may or
may not enable us to form certain
hypotheses in a different study we
identified 20 gene prognostic signatures
from surrounding stroma in lung cancer
and I want to highlight the aspect that
because a lot of these analyses used in
which men analysis use mapping to a
protein interaction network we study
only small fraction of the genome
we have well-characterized on the
interaction network and ignore
everything else prove to the story are
using interaction database that
integrates multiple curated in
high-throughput databases we can take
the 20 genes which are the square on the
outside and identify how they link on a
protein interaction level what is not
surprising that they don't interact
directly if they would interact directly
likely there will be redundant and we
would have 19 or 18 gene signature not
20 what is important though that they
strongly linked to this middle layer of
proteins that interconnect multiple
proteins from the signature those are
the red edges and those proteins are
highly interconnected into highly
connected components which are the blue
edges so we now have a very interesting
potential story of how those 20 genes
relate to the biology to the signaling
cascade and so on using exactly the same
analysis but only one of the databases
HP rd for example clearly shows you that
there is plenty of proteins that have
absolutely no connection so we cannot
even start making any discussion about
what potentially relates among these
individual proteins so skeptics may
argue that obviously there could be
noise here because we are integrating
multiple types of data but we have a
very good clinical context that enable
us to validate specific interactions if
they prove to be useful and it's better
to have information that we can validate
as opposed to have absolutely no
information and blindly sit and not do
anything obviously as we integrate more
data the network stands to be more dense
and so we had to start kind of thinking
about the scalability of graph
theoretical algorithms that can go into
and detangle these large large networks
but we still need more of those protein
interactions because at least ten
percent of the protein interactions
remains unknown and we had to analyze
them because they relate to multiple
different diseases regardless of what we
look at either census mutations or
homing disease database or our canceled
a tight integration portal zero or low
degree proteins are strongly linked to
multiple diseases across this profile so
we had to really find different methods
for this interaction
prediction we divide one such method and
as in traditional machine learning
algorithm approach we identify true
positive protein interactions and
identify those unlikely interactions as
a starting point for a training set and
then describe those both set in terms of
different features and the combination
of features feature set from gene
ontology from sequence information
expression profiles and so on then each
of the pairs of potential pairs of
interacting partners were further
identified through co-expression
expression of three different tissues
homologs orthologs and also protein
interaction data when we combine all of
these different pieces of evidence
through noisy or we can identify
probability with evidence from
individual sets and feature set that can
identify should be fine no we started
later but okay so what is interesting
about the integration is that individual
features like for example topology from
the network is useful up to a certain
point and then it becomes useless
because we are in a very sparse or
completely disconnected part of the
network and what is important is that
when we combine those pieces of evidence
even at the time when we have very
little information available from single
features the combined features can still
actually provide reasonable prediction
accuracy to validate it we looked into
multiple different ways of comparing to
existing prediction algorithms but also
to high-throughput assays is for example
in a without group there were five
high-throughput acids compared on a true
positives and true negatives all of the
green blocks basically identify true
positive interactions and these are the
false discovery rate what is important
is that none of these five methods but
there were no mass spec for example they
were only run once and so on so there
are many technical reasons for why they
miss forty-one percent of the
interactions but what is important is
that the computational prediction
identifies ninety-one percent of
interactions with only one percent false
discovery rate so it
quite favorably compares to a
high-throughput method quite comparable
to or much better in terms of the false
discovery rate and sensitivity to other
prediction algorithms and also through
very extensive three different way
validation across novel mammoth skewing
GST pulao in co IP significantly
increasing the validation where it's
compared to biological assays so
combination of computational predictions
with biological validation significantly
improved sensitivity of these asses and
we can go after novel targets one of the
such example was EGFR very important
protein in receptor protein in lung
cancer and the idea was not only to
identify and validate interaction novel
interactions for egfr but also then look
at the wild-type versus specific mutant
l85 a dar which is frequenting lung
cancer how mutation effects interacting
partners so all of these dots in here
are basically validated protein
interactions but what you can identifies
that those that are more on the upper
side are specific to mutant version of
egfr well this dome on the lower side
are specific to the wild-type version
when you look into these individual dots
most of them are triangles either
pointing up or down and that's from the
cancer data integration portal if we
know that those genes are up or down
regulated in lung cancer and those that
are highlighted with red are prognostic
genes in lung cancer so it's not
surprising most of the interacting
partners of egfr are related or
deregulated in lung cancer but long
story short we picked one of those crk
and what was interesting is when we
combine it with the shrna screen we're
able to identify that knocking it down
increases a lot in of sensitivity and
validating it at least on a cell line
that we can combine the regulated genes
signatures protein interactions
predictions another type of data in
order to identify potentially novel set
of patients that can be treated with
available treatment strategy these
interactions are really essential
because as mentioned earlier we can
combine novel high-throughput
green with noble predictions and only
then we can actually understand how and
why drugs work so this is highlighting
drug target and this is highlighting
genes that we know are deregulated from
transcriptional profiles by those drugs
and is highlighted here novel mid screen
and interactions through i2d it's the
combination of those interactions that
we need to have in order to understand
what's the linkage between the drug
target and jeans they are
transcriptionally modulated by specific
drug so considering that this is really
useful we switch gears and integrated
other prediction algorithms and now
extended a number of interactions for
human for example to over 800,000
interactions and covering almost the
full proteome as we know it and also
then going through five other model
organisms what is important that we can
then annotate mostly for human and mouse
but also sporadically for other other
organisms when available what's the
expression of these targets and these
interactions and conservation of these
interactions across different species
and across different tissues and that's
potentially starting to detangle not
only that ok we have a putative 800,000
interaction network for human but in
which tissue under what condition in
which disease are these interactions may
be very typically interesting or or
useful so in order to be roughly on time
I will skip fifth through few other
examples then I will jump to the end and
one of the examples I didn't have time
to go into but it's related to the
aspect of we have large number of
information on on molecular profiles and
some information on the clinical
information about patient and what is
amazing is you can open any journal
these days and if there is a clinical
study people will refer to BMI body mass
index and what is shocking is that in
this day of age where we have other
alternatives for several months and
years available it's really useless
because when we look into schwarzenegger
and danny devito they have pretty much
the same BMI and nobody will convince me
that
of the health and fitness level there
will be anywhere to be comparable so we
try to compare molecule profiles and
identify what are the risk factors for
individual patients based on a BMI it's
completely useless it's like using same
clock and a digital clock at the same
time so what is important we have to use
different methods and there are methods
available for example for BMI we can use
data fusion in order to reduce some of
the false positives and through
prominence we can also ensure that we
can control what false positives and
false negatives and through integrative
analysis will be able to refine
evidence-based medicine because there
are many many errors in the literature
and again one of the aspects that I
skipped through is I don't know how many
people looked into increasing amount of
retracted papers in the literature last
year it was about five percent of the
papers we're retracting and is
exponentially increasing over the last
few years and many times when you find a
discovery or we create the model we find
some interesting findings and we have a
trouble of convincing it was also
discussed yesterday convincing reviewers
what is right what is wrong because
there is a published literature that
shows otherwise and in these studies it
actually shows that large fraction of
these papers will be eventually
retracted most of these papers are
clinical and thus we have to really be
rigorous in terms of how we prove or
disprove what is true what is right I
would like to acknowledge a lot of
collaborators across different diseases
some of them I didn't mention here but
obviously its collective work that led
to some of these findings and I
highlighted some of the people involved
in the lab but obviously programmers
that enable that these servers are up
and running our essential part of the
lab and if people are interested servers
are available with this data at
different parts and I will be happy to
take any questions
I can start with the immediate question
is there any real computational
challenge in figuring out duplicates in
data anyhow the IDS may be different but
can't you just tell immediately by
looking at the data set or is it is it
going to be slightly different here and
there slightly different one aspect
might be that there would be different
platform that was used for example so
you cannot kind of really find a carbon
copy of the data it yeah it's just I
mean sometimes you really had to go into
supplemental Excel spreadsheets to
identify patient ID that eventually you
trace it back that is the same sample I
mean the sample from the same patient
that is used in multiple different data
set and detect ultra shoes and
essentially she obviously replicating
your results so maybe the key question
here is in order to is it really an
integration issue or is it making sure
that the kind of data that we look at is
comparing apples and apples and nothing
nothing more just so I take it I mean at
different steps it must've in terms of
the curation it's really ensuring that
we curate and clean the data before we
put it into the pipelines the next
aspect is that once we start integrating
call it different pipelines into
identifying more cross platform cross
entity measurements that's where the
network's coming and obviously depends
on what networks are using in a sense is
it is it reducing the error or noise or
is it increasing it and what's the
relevance obviously at one point when
everything will be connected to
everything is not going to be useful
right so that's also one of the reasons
why we still need more of the
interactions we still need more of the
micro native gene targets but and we
also now really strongly will need to
contextualize these networks because at
one level as I said I mean everything
will be connected to everything but the
question is in lung cancer when we have
EGFR mutation with portion of these
network is relevant in ovarian cancer
when we have musing a subtype different
sub different configuration of this
network might be relevant so it's going
to be contextualizing it and then
analyzing that contextualized version or
instance of a network so what exactly is
the difference
and say a bag of genes or proteins and I
just wasn't clear so signature in my
definition is that it has either
prognostic or predictive value so either
you can identify patients with a high or
low risk or you can identify for example
which patients will or will not respond
to a specific treatment I understand the
goal of the signature but what is in the
signature like a bunch of genes there mr
proteins yeah mrna levels and that's it
was like connection the other
non-additive terms in the signature
non-additive terms it's just a factor
pretty much it's just a selection of
genes and protein levels specific
selection but what is important is that
there are not necessarily as I was
highlighting not necessarily the most
differential so we don't really have
still a good way of identifying the best
signature and as I also highlighted is
that it there is no such thing as this
is the best signature because or this is
the best set of genes because we are
looking for less than 10 gene signature
you can rank few thousand of them based
on for example hazard ratios have you
can validate them on independent data
set but if we will be looking for say
fifty gene or fifty protein signature it
will be a different set of genes or
proteins so the point you made about the
best supporting
by networks they will differ in a test
fit so the example I was showing on
ovarian cancer we started with hundred
and fourteen genes that were highly
differential across large set of samples
then we expanded it to close to 600
proteins that were connecting among
themselves from the DN 8514 genes based
on independent validation and cross
validation that were now a strong
prognostic signature in ovarian cancer
and what was interesting is that only
two of those 14 genes actually came from
those highly differential jeans
everything else were inject connectors
from the network so that's one of the
kind of highlight that it's through the
network that we can find clinically more
interesting set of genes or proteins
that can validate on independent data
sets and also the malla date on a
protein level and we have some I didn't
show but we have some nerve validation
through the mouse models of really the
biology of why and how the disease
progresses and it's only because we were
able to expand it through the protein
interaction network we would not find it
if we would focus just on a differential
genes so you should take the rest of the
questions of life speak your good